las vegas's own tony fields looks like
he walks around in shoulder pads
well that's just the way he's built like
a linebacker ready to hear his name
called in the 2021 draft
and when that day comes it'll be earned
tony fields handles the draft day weight
by moving massive weight
day after day rep after rep i mean it's
been something i look forward to all my
life i've had dreams about it
the past three weeks every other day so
i'm just having dreams about what will
happen tony has a track record of being
a ball
seeking star he shined on the first
desert pines team to win a state
championship
he took his talents to tucson and
graduated early and then the vegas kid
rolled the dice on his future spent
three years at arizona
and then kobe had hit and i had to
make changes i mean i went all the way
across the country to a
place i've never been before fields
didn't arrive to campus
until the fall but fit in like country
roads at west virginia
and was first team all big 12. never
been in snow really before
except a couple times that it drizzled
out here in vegas but
i mean that's nothing compared to being
in morgantown it's snowing all week and
me having to drive for my first time in
snow
so it was pretty different but i feel
like it was great to adapt to change
in college because coming up here
shortly i'm going to adapt to change for
the rest of my life
fields now fits with a different figure
in high school he was 192
pounds now he's tackling 230 and has
every nfl team
flexing interest i met with all 32 teams
some
more than one time i mean one coach
pulled up some film of me playing uh
offense in
high school tony has a chance to be the
first las vegas kid to grow up
and play for las vegas i mean it would
be great to play for the hometown team i
mean i love to
be here you know support vegas but
either way i mean no matter where i am
i'm still going to be a vegas native i'm
still going to come back here as a
projected middle round draft pick
a lifetime of pushing and pulling
will soon pay